what this gold teach you about money
nothing I'll tell you go to school get a
job no jobs work hard pay taxes get out
of debt safe on it and invest in the
stock market stupid I won't do that
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to get
rich with Rich Dad Robert Kiyosaki okay
let's kick it off with rule number one
get real financial education what this
gold teach you about money
nothing I'll tell you I go to school get
a job no jobs work hard pay taxes get
out of debt save money and invest in the
stock market stupid I won't do that
basics are this okay in the world of
money there's three types of income so
this is financial education so if I was
teaching a bunch of let's say high
school sophomores at fifteen I say
there's three kinds of income it's a
very important word okay
and number one it's called earned income
this is what they what happens when you
go to school and you get a job and you
work for money earned income is you
working for money it's the highest taxed
income that's why that advice go to
school get a job and work hard you're
working for
you pay law tax the second type of
income is portfolio income I should get
portfolio income is also called capital
gains that's when you buy low sell high
so that's portfolio and I don't know the
tax rate but years ago is about 20% you
know I forget now it's changed so most
people when they go to school they get a
job they were for earned income and they
invest for a long term of the stock
market investing for portfolio income
and the third type of income is the
income that myself and cam and Kenny all
my advisers invest on your parents it's
called passive and the reason passive
income is good is because no attacks
it's wonderful stuff so that's kind of
those are the three types of income so
if I was teaching a bunch of high school
kids I said when you leave school here
today the big question in your mind is
what kind of income do I want for the
rest of my life well I wanted passive
and the average person because I have a
job is working for earned income which
is the highest tax you get tired working
for that so when you look at again the
rich dead financial statement here
income expands assets and liabilities
okay so earned income is this here
that's earned okay when you when you
work for and then the problem with that
income is tax then the if you're working
for portfolio income you're generally
working for this you buy a stock
Follette say Apple for ten bucks and it
goes to 50 bucks and you sell it the
trouble with that again is X but if you
work for passive income but your mom and
dad work for is this is passive income
here okay it's cash flow it's also
called so that's what I'm the cash flow
boardgame pictured here so all I wanted
was passive income so what I have today
is I have about seven thousand rental
properties I've what tells golf courses
oil in all this but again it goes back
to these three types of income earned
portfolio and passive so if I was
talking to a bunch of high school kids
we've been elementary school kids it's
not that hard but I'm glad you asked the
question because I think a lot of a lot
of young people can think nothing well
why am I in school I don't know you know
if you just want to work hard and pay
taxes on earned income and flip real
estate or flip houses then you're
working for portfolio yeah I don't flip
yeah that's a very big difference I
don't like to buy low and sell high
that's flipping that's called capital
gains in4 which is portfolio I in fought
for cash flow which is passive and I can
turn cap
I can turn capital gains into passive
myths so it gets crazier and crazier and
crazier from there on also if you want
to have more self-love and motivation
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join are in the description
below I don't cheat on my wife I don't
cheat on my customers I don't cheat
people I don't cut corners if I can't do
something I'll tell you upfront if I
screw up I'll tell you most phd's tell
me I can't write yes I said I can't
write
I can't sell look I haven't I have an
unfair advantage you know I went to war
and at war I'm alive because other guys
died for me
rule number two choose your teachers
wisely the lesson is you got choose your
teachers wisely when the market crashed
in 2008 gets so much money I borrowed a
lot 300 million no way from our
investors the banker how's that how does
that work because interest rates for
dropping and real estate prices were
going to the toilet and when I walk into
my bank or the split Rich Dad Poor Dad
about this airport has about a financial
statement ankle statement balance sheet
statement of cash flows a book on
accounting people don't even know it's a
book on accounting so I walked into my
bank with my partner that all this
property I was floating to the surface
and I say I'll take them off your hands
I just give me give me the money to buy
the property Wow that's the holiest 300
million give me the money and I'll buy
your property that's crazy
so it depends and this is my whole thing
I am now 700 million almost a billion in
debt premi you know why because I don't
pay any taxes the more antenna I have
the less tax okay and the average guy
goes how do you do that because you have
bad teachers and so it's this whole
thing that you got choose your teachers
wisely that's why I wrote the book fake
fake money fake teachers fake assets I
don't touch that garbage of Wall Street
puts out I don't have a 401k I don't
have stocks mom there's a Ponzi TS
doesn't mean you shouldn't but I don't
need them okay right and the other part
is look for young guys the best teachers
are not in colleges the best teacher are
on YouTube the best teachers are on
YouTube wake up yeah this guy George
gammon he's fantastic
Patrick met David fantastic you know
he's great records the fake teachers are
in colleges they're telling to get a job
right the corporate ladder you know
Patrick bet David said it the best and I
love that guy he says there's two kinds
of leaders wartime and
each time and a piece 10 liters of
garlic my poor debt he goes through all
the right schools here's all the
pedigrees cadential he does all the
right things he climbs a corporate or
government ladder and all that
well wartime leader goes goes to war so
jobs Steve John the wartime leader I'm a
wartime differences I went to war I went
to war twice on the frontlines yeah and
I checked what happened so I joined the
Marine Corps got a flight pool in
Pensacola I learned to fly but a Camp
Pendleton I strapped on my weapons I go
to advanced weapons and camp Alton I go
to Okinawa and then they send me in to
Vietnam and I came out of Vietnam about
four months later back to back to
restage at Okinawa and I thought
everybody had changed I looked at the
fellow Marines I thought and it wasn't
that they were I had been to war mmm
you got tougher it's different when
someone's trying to kill you every
single mission I went down three times
no way yeah and I came back stronger and
tougher so I come back to Okinawa I got
like a week off and they're gonna ship
me back into Vietnam again I said what
happened to these guys and it wasn't
that they change I changed so what
happens to entrepreneurs who go out and
they get their ass handed to them and
they survive if you survive you see the
world service and that's what happened
to you when you get injured at all this
yeah you see a different world whereas
some peacetime who's climbing the
corporate ladder right now they just
lost their job they're sucking their
thumb yeah this is the worst time for
yet for a wartime leader this we're
excited they're excited about it yeah
it's the best of times yeah Ossipon or
right now the world is open to you
you're an employee
your worlds dead to you what is yeah an
entrepreneur can create their own
success and for the people that are the
wartime people what is the the best
advice you would give them now for the
next year two years two
capitalize on how do they make more
money how do they make their Millions
during this time what would you get who
can't make money now should hang it up I
tell all freaking Millennials man I got
this iPhone if you had make money with
that hang it up
you know like we used to say hang up the
jockstrap you know okay
you can't make money with an iPhone
through social media through marketing
you have the world at your fingertips
and you can't make money the problem is
between this year and this year not out
here it's in here that's why you've got
to choose your teachers wisely yeah you
know so let me just say it again the
best teachers are on YouTube so what's
the best portal take up your mind make a
good night with you I'll listen to you
don't nice so yeah I'm just being real I
hear you what's what's the best
investment people can make then to to
operate capitalizing this opportunity is
the investment in education left if
you're poor right now it was called look
in the mirror
that's another always said to me if
you're looking in the mirror right now
you see a loser that's what you are
can't make money in this economy you
don't change I think you know hindsight
is 20/20
yes yes almost if you're looking at me
no you don't have any money you don't
have a job the boyfriend or girlfriend
has left you and soon they go so well
how did I get here how did I get here
there's a great book called uh you know
Gulag Archipelago by Solzhenitsyn so he
gets thrown in this in a concentration
camp or a gulag in Siberia and he says
how did I get here
you know how you got there because he
was a peacetime later mm-hmm and fight
back so people are being sold until go
to school get a job pay taxes save money
get out of debt buy a house
as an asset and invest for the long-term
in a well-defined portfolio of stocks
bonds mutual funds and ETS and I do none
of that and why do you recommend the
opposite I don't have to do that Pratt
that's that's cool eight go to the
school go to school look they teach
about money nothing get a job you pay
the highest taxes pay your taxes I don't
pay taxes get out of debt well debt
money is dead after 1971 for you know
you history buddy your house is not an
acid house it's a liability and why
would an investor long-term the stock
market when I can make my own assets I
don't need the stock market unless say
you shouldn't mm-hmm I create my own
assets I create my own cash flow every
day you mean through your business
through your your right your creativity
I'm an entrepreneur yeah most people are
employees and rule number three the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
don't hang out with losers there are
people who want to go into real estate
but they have then they have the
negative Midas Touch everything they
turn they touch turns are you know
doesn't turn to gold and they no matter
what piece of real estate another what
stock they go into they have a losers
mentality and that's why I don't hang
out with posers well I'm a good
hardworking person I say no but you're a
laborer you're not an investor you don't
understand me but I'm a good person I go
to church every Sunday I work hard I
said yeah but you're still a loser it
doesn't mean you're a bad person does
that make sense you guys hear you're a
loser you're a financial little sir
that's what it means it doesn't mean I
don't want a bad partner now I've got a
special bonus gift from Robert on how to
question everything that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day I want to
know who are the teachers that you want
to now surround yourself with to learn
more and improve your financial
education let me know put your thoughts
down in the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video you're still
here watching then you promise you
commit to yourself that you're gonna
take action we don't just watch videos
hear believe nation we do something
about it
give me a hashtag believed on the
comments below if that's you so I can
celebrate with YouTube most of your
viewers out there sitting inside their
head or their words from their mother
and father go to school get a job pay
taxes save money buy a house cuz it's an
asset get out of debt
yeah and invest in the stock market that
creates poor people it's a hypnosis
train going through your brain so when
people say how do I change my life or
you change those words I wouldn't go to
school because you learned nothing about
money in school ask I wouldn't get a job
because if I have a job I'm an employee
and then I'd pay taxes and I don't pay
taxes and I don't save money and I use
debt to get rich and I don't invest in
the stock market that's why I'm rich and
so the young people who are listening
right now are the same but that's what
my mom and dad said but that's what mom
and dad say all over the world so to the
young people I just say challenge or
question what you've been taught because
from the Bible I'm not religious yeah
the word becomes flesh so if you say go
to school nice but I'll learn nothing
about money get a job we've become an
employee yeah if you're an employee you
work for money I pay taxes then they
tell you to save money why would you
save money when the government is
printing money you know and get out of
debt well
debt is money I use debt to get rich
most videos debt to get poor and invest
in the stock market I don't invest in
the stock market so when you when you
wonder why so many people struggle
financially because they haven't
challenged the hypnosis the words go to
school get a job
save money get paid taxes until you
question those hypnotic trances you
don't change
if you want to learn how to develop an
insane work ethic check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there hardwood working a little bit hard
at work I think very hard-working go
hard work ethic what work ethic